jessica mendoza the espn baseball
analyst part of the broadcast team for
the world series on espn radio
and they'll be on the call tonight at 7
30 eastern and last night she made
history becoming the first female to
serve as an
analyst for a world series game on any
platform nationally
she's alongside dan shulman and chris
singleton
jessica good morning if i told you 20
years ago you would be doing this in the
world series
you would have said what
that's a great question i mean i
wouldn't have believed it just because
i mean i was just trying to make it as a
softball player like i wouldn't have
believed i would have gone to the
olympics like honestly i think i was
just trying to figure out life
at that point but i think more
importantly dan like you just weren't
hearing women right
you know i i watched a ton of sports
like we all did growing up
and women's voices let alone women's
sports
but hearing women on mail events uh just
it didn't happen i i definitely never
heard it as much as i loved listening to
all the
the guys that i grew up listening to it
just wasn't even on your radar
and when you hear that voice and you
don't know what
impact you've had on somebody but maybe
15 years from now you're gonna find out
when somebody walks up
to you and says i listen to you on radio
and because of that i decided to do this
like you're gonna have you're gonna
you're gonna mean something to a lot of
people but you're gonna mean something
to
some some girls some women who are
listening to this and you may never know
so
uh it may not be impactful as much to
people now but it's going to be
impactful i think
down the road so congratulations on that
and and i hope you savor the moment
yeah i think one of the biggest things
that i've learned is yes the impact on
young girls but
really like what i've heard back from
just even doing television
is dads like a lot of fathers that are
out there
that you know they've watched sports and
they've got daughters but they never
really made that transition in their
mind of like
can my daughter do this and i've heard
from more fathers that were like
when i first heard you i didn't like it
like i was like what is this
well guys don't want to be told about
sports by a woman
totally like and we're honest with me
but then they're like all of a sudden my
little six-year-old plopped down on the
couch next to me and was like
is that a girl daddy is that a girl and
just an
effective change of like oh wait
like this can impact the people that i
love and care about and that to me like
yes the girls the women of course that's
the obvious
but there's a lot of men out there that
i feel like that that's just as
important too that's great
but do you feel like you have to prove
yourself every game
oh yeah i mean like and it's not even
like
proving it for me like i i feel caught
like my prep like you know
i i know that i've got this but there is
definitely and i felt it yesterday to be
honest with you
is like i started to feel those nerves
of like
don't screw up like you have zero
zero room for error because this door
has been open and
we're coming through but like we don't
want that door to ever close again
and there's a responsibility there like
if i mess up like that door could get
shut and be like okay we're not gonna
have women doing world series games
anymore
how would a great hitter let's say
mookie betts
is at the plate against the best
softball pitcher
how would mookie do
i think mookie would take a lot of
pitches foul off
a bunch and find like scrappy way he's
not getting a home run in fact he's not
going to slug
against the softball pitcher no but like
grind
and i feel like he'd get like a key walk
like he'd lay off the rice ball after
trying to swing at it and kind of
looking like okay i have no chance on
hitting that
so i'm gonna take that [ __ ] and he'd
learn within the about you'd literally
see him
change within and at bat to figure out a
way to get on base knowing like i'm not
gonna crush any of these [ __ ]
i'm glad that america is seeing mookie
betts like
even when he was with boston you would
think that you know the rest of the
baseball world would notice this or the
casual fan but
he still is we talk about mike trout as
a five tool player like mookie betts to
me
like he would back up first base on a
throw
from the pitch like just small little
things that we noticed playing the game
and i i just love that we're focusing on
defense he had the audacity to steal a
base
two bases last night jessica doesn't he
know about the analytics you're not
supposed to steal bases
like what's wrong with mookie betts it
was like the first player since babe
ruth 19 i mean that tells you where the
game has been no
you don't even see a stolen place let
alone two and by the way he pretty much
stole home like the high home view of
him getting that jump on the weak ground
ball like he was going it was like a
squeeze play
he was all in he read the swing before
there was even contact made
what did we learn about the dodgers last
night
i mean we stopped i think clayton
kershaw leads that with like
him not coming back in the seventh i
think we saw an evolution of dave
roberts
and seeing that clayton kershaw had his
stuff he had a great start
it's game one i think last year shoot
last five years clayton kershaw runs out
there in the seventh maybe the eighth
and at some point he gets hit and we're
talking three four runs the razor in
this game
clayton kershaw's narrative continues
instead you saw the frustration of the
dugout he won i mean 78 pitches
like yeah he could have gone back out
there but the understanding of like
we've got a rested bullpen we've got
guys behind him
when he struggles in the postseason it's
when he's left in too long
so i think to me that's first and
foremost what you learned the most about
the dodgers is they are
learning and evolving from the mistakes
they've made in the past
so what do you expect to happen tonight
in this chess match between these two
well i mean the dodgers have to go to a
bullpen game and this is the difference
of the alcs
ending a day earlier is that they were
able to line up their guys now blake
snell
2018 cy young award winner like he's got
this stuff
but oh damn like oh my gosh like
watching him
struggle through like a hundred plus
pitches his last two starts in like
three in the third innings
i mean buckle up fans like this is not
the best of baseball when you'll watch
especially combined with the dodgers
offense like
not because they're explosive which they
are but they're patient
and blake snell doesn't throw a lot of
strikes he gets you to try and chase
and you're gonna see ball one ball two
ball three maybe some foul pitches
it's gonna be a long and he's gonna
literally just try to get them to chase
and for the dodgers on the flip side i
mean it's a bullpen game
but they're going to have to use a lot
of their guys i think to mix and match
because that's what the rays do i mean
they go left right left right and
they're going to try to play that chess
match
and i i don't know it's hard to go in as
a favorite
you know when you play like you're
supposed to win the dodgers are supposed
to win
and you know people will probably
criticize them if they win in six games
like
you guys should win in five or four
whatever it is and kershaw goes out to
the mound like he's
he's always expected to win i don't know
what that feels like because i was never
a favorite
but can you sense it with the dodgers
that
they're prohibited favors they're
supposed to win they spent all this
money
tampa bay they spend like you know 58
cents on their roster
i i don't know how how hard it is to
play
and then play with that pressure on top
of you
yeah i i sensed it the most in that
brave series in the nlcs them losing
those first two games they weren't
enjoying themselves and i mean dan like
i
played tm usa like the only thing to win
was gold like literally a silver medal
was a failure like i know pressure i
understand it and i recognize it and the
dodgers have had it for years now
but let's like be real it's it's as high
as it's ever been
this year because it's not the yankees
on the other side it's not this big huge
powerhouse
what everyone talked about coming into
the season in tampa bay i mean
let's give them credit they're the best
record in the american league
but the dodgers all eyes are on them if
they do not win
this world series they are a failed team
tampa bay yes they want to win it all
but the fact that they've gotten here
and what they've been able to do to get
here beating the yankees beating the
astros that the most hated team in
baseball like
they've already won the dodgers have to
win it all
if you're clayton kershaw and uh you
could choose
that the dodgers sweep the race and you
don't pitch again in the series
or you start game five and you're
leading three games to one
which one would clayton kershaw take oh
game five
oh i mean this is part of his not demise
i don't want to say that but like
knowing you could have
a championship i mean he would want that
championship
he is a team player but like he also
wants the ball i mean in game seven
on sunday he was in the bullpen he was
like
i mean he still has that like give me
the ball
i want to help the difference is dan
this year
it's not about him like which is a great
thing it's not all clayton kershaw on
his shoulders if he doesn't win his
games
they don't win like there is the mookie
bets the walker buellers i mean there's
so much
talent now more than ever that it really
isn't about him and he doesn't have to
take the ball
or get the ball i brought this up prior
to the start of the show and and my guys
the danettes looked at me like i was
crazy
do you think one day we'll see a team
adopt like
whitey herzog's cardinals approach where
we're going to we're going to run we're
going to get on base
we're going to have um great defense
we're gonna
run down everything in the outfield uh
we're gonna take the extra bit like
instead of what it is now is somebody
gonna be
are they gonna counter program baseball
like teams are trying to counter program
the golden state warriors
i don't see it i i would love to see it
i mean
you have to have that in your team i
think to win
a championship you have to have the
ability to play defense
to get on base just put the ball in play
i mean will smith had a hit
you know i think it was a game game
seven where he literally
just jammed himself and went the
opposite way to beat the shift like such
like
old school nobody does that no they
won't even take a bunt they won't
i don't understand it i i don't
understand i'm too old jessica
no and dan i'm with you i just the games
that are won
are won by the long ball the numbers
show it and so more teams are going to
go after guys and i know this is like
cringing
like and i get it the strikeouts are an
all-time high
but teams win based on the amount of
home runs they hit if you out home or
the other team you win the game
that's like basically what it's you
don't see guys stealing bases you don't
see like the emphasis on just pure
defense
and i'm with you i mean i love long
balls of course you want that
but you have to have a combination so i
would like to see i think the perfect
team
has the understanding that you need both
but you see more gms go after
guys that strike out can't really move
but they can hit home runs
but do you think the pitching approach
will change that everybody throws 100
now so it's
it's a it's a novelty if you don't throw
100
can you see where you're gonna have guys
who
work the corners who you know off-speed
stuff instead of
my power versus your power i think
you'll see those guys but they'll be
out of the bullpen more a specialist i
mean to see them in a starter
is more rare like the dallas kykels that
you know
just break in 80 like bottom of the zone
hit your corners kenta maeda had a
really good year
for the minnesota twins he was a dodger
and but look at when he was with the
dodgers
he was out of the bullpen i mean they
didn't even use him as a starter he's
the ace for the minnesota twins because
they understand
the value in that but i think what we
see now is the guys that
either because they drop down or they're
able to just hit their spots locate
they're not striking guys out but
they're getting that weak contact
those are guys that just honestly they
analytics don't show they can go two
times
times through the lineup so you only see
them in the seventh inning have fun
tonight
and uh congrats um and uh please tell
dan shulman i said hello one of the uh
the great people not only great
broadcasters but uh please tell dan i
said hello
it's been awesome to do these games with
him and reunite dan thank you
so much thank you jessica jessica
mendoza be on the call espn radio
tonight that's at
7 30 eastern